au sommaire ce soir la chasse à l'homme
dans la région lyonnaise pour tenter
d'appréhender un suspect qui pourrait
être fait fort à l'été le cal il en
cause dans les derniers attentats
la remise en liberté de l'ancien maire
de nice jacques médecin à la suite du
procès carignon les projets fiscaux du
gouvernement qui suscite pas mal de
remous
la grogne des navigants d'air france et
d'air inter en grève pour deux jours
la visite de yasser arafat à paris et
pour la première fois des images de sa
fille zawa et la rencontre jean paul ii
brigitte bardot madame monsieur bonsoir
chasse à l'homme dans la région paris et
lyonnaise pardon pour tenter
d'appréhender un fuyard qui pourrait
être khaled kelkal soupçonné vous savoir
à vous le savez d'avoir participé à
certains des derniers attentats
à l'origine un simple contrôle de
gendarmerie qui s'est terminée par une
fusillade reportage d'une aiguille au
film fives et il est un peu plus de neuf
heures lorsque d'aller au barça depuis
deux mois
moi même allons jouer à ses côtés
plusieurs armes de gros calibre et des
sacs et non loin de là un deuxième homme
qui fait le guet sur vide alors une
patrouille de gendarmes les deux
ramasseurs de champignons vont
immédiatement les prévenir mais dans le
même temps une renault 9 avec deux
hommes à son bord arrivée de jeunes
algériens
bien sûr je les ai vu une erreur
d'offres au rouge
il avait le a comme un nouveau corps du
tort deux jeunes il avait une casquette
les quatre hommes avaient
vraisemblablement rendez-vous à la vue
des gendarmes
des coups de feu éclatent j'ai entendu
deux coups de feu je sais qu'il ya pas
de charge pour lui donc je trouve les
fameux 10 eur puis à un moment après je
donc j'ai aperçu et des hélicoptères ec
égyptiens c'est là où les gendarmes
arrêteront l'un des quatre hommes et
blessant grièvement un deuxième qui sera
évacué en hélicoptère une gigantesque
chasse à l'homme est alors organisée 200
gendarmes sont mobilisés avec notre
chien hélicoptère un troisième suspect
repéré et arrêté il s'était réfugié dans
une grange est alors qu'il est le
quatrième court toujours
le terrain fortement escarpé et très
boisées ce qui ne facilite pas les
recherches et passent au peigne fin
ce n'est qu'une hypothèse mais l'homme
dangereux et muni d'un fusil à pompe qui
est recherché pourrait bien n'être
khaled kelkal le signalement correspond
ses complices sont originaires de vaulx
en velin et surtout sur place les
enquêteurs ont découvert 300 cartouches
des fusils une mitraillette mais aussi
un coran et des documents islamistes
d'ailleurs dans l'après midi la section
antiterroriste du parquet de paris a été
saisi avec les stocks tortora un rappel
des charges qui pèsent sur cet algérien
de 24 ans depuis maintenant deux mois
toutes les polices de france sont à la
recherche de cet homme khaled kelkal
depuis que ses empreintes ont été
retrouvées sur les rubans adhésifs qui
entourait le dispositif de mise à feu
d'une bonbonne de gaz
la bombe n'avait pas explosé au passage
du tgv elles avaient été déposés le long
de la ligne paris-lyon khaled kelkal
n'est pas un inconnu des services de
police le 10 juillet dernier il avait
forcé un barrage près de bron ces
empreintes retrouvées dans la voiture
avait permis de remonter jusqu'à lui
dans sa voiture également des douilles
du même type que celle laissée sur place
par les tueurs du chèque sahraouis début
juillet à paris
depuis deux mois on avait cru le voir
dans un supermarché à paris ou encore en
bretagne il était devenu le suspect
numéro un
c'est peut-être lui qui a à nouveau
aujourd'hui tenté de forcer un barrage
jacques médecin a été remis en liberté
en fin d'après-midi par décision de la
cour d'appel de grenoble et cela à la
suite semble-t-il d'un vice de procédure
le procès en appel de l'ancien maire de
nice dans la sphère du sert elle a été
renvoyée au 29 novembre sur place
thierry kurt et pascal 40
les tous derniers instants de jacques
médecin en prison quelques minutes plus
tard il est dehors a respiré un grand
bol d'air frais sa liberté toute
provisoire mais c'est la liberté tout de
même que c'est le but le comme disait
churchill commencement de la fin
bien sûr il y a encore la peine tu vas
être jugé je ne peux pas préjuger de ce
que sera cet appel de ce que sera son
verdict
enfin chez des gens au moins la
possibilité de respirer l'air libre
l'air l'air de verre de france jusqu'au
mois de novembre
retour sur le début d'après midi jacques
médecin arrive en tant que détenu au
tribunal de grenoble pour être jugé en
appel dans le cadre de la sphère de la
serre elle en première instance il a été
condamné à trois ans et demi de prison
pour avoir facilité l'obtention de
marchés publics pour cette société de
signalisation la serre elle lui aurait
ensuite versé 4 millions de francs
c'était pour financer ma vie politique
d'alors dire à jacques médecin
il ne s'attend pas du tout être remise
en liberté
la cour arrive et là stupeur sur les
quatre prévenus deux n'ont pas été
convoqués et l'un des deux est carrément
absents le tribunal de grenoble a envoyé
les convocations au tribunal de nice
pour qu'il n'ait répercute tout à fait
normalement
mais le tribunal de nice n'a pas fait
suivre
c'est incroyable négligence judiciaire
rend impossible la tenue d'un procès
équitable
l'avocat général décide alors de
renvoyer l'audience au 29 novembre et le
détenu jacques médecin ne devons pas
subir les carences judiciaire il ne
s'oppose pas à la remise en liberté de
l'ancien maire de nice du coup ce soir
jacques médecin est momentanément libre
il dort chez sa soeur à paris
a lyon troisième jour du procès d'alain
carignon accusé de corruption lors de la
concession au privé de la distribution
de l'eau municipale de grenoble qui dit
corruption dit contrepartie en argent ou
en nature
et ce sont ces éventuelles contreparties
qui ont été examinés aujourd'hui par le
tribunal
compte rendu d'audience dominique
verdeilhan denis par vanins alain
carignon est un homme de communication
il connaît le sens des mots il sait que
juridiquement il ya une différence entre
avantages et contreparties pour
l'accusation les faveurs dont aurait
bénéficié l'ancien ministre s'élève à
plus de 20 millions de francs elles
seraient des contreparties au contrat de
concession des eaux de pronos d'abord
l'appartement de 280 m² vous vers saint
germain à paris mis à sa disposition par
le groupe merlin
je n'y ai vu ni malice ni corruption dit
alain carignon je ne me suis jamais
considéré comme locataire ou comme
maître des lieux
ensuite les vols en avion taxi sur les
141 vols qu'on me reproche je n'en n'ai
effectué que 49 à des fins politiques
trois sont des voyages d'agrément ce
sont des vols de trop je reconnais ma
peau 9 michel merlin est également
prudent sur les mots il parle lui aussi
davantage de services mais à demi mot il
laisse entendre que plus tard il a pilé
demande d'alain carignon pour des
contreparties avantage contre partie le
choix des mots n'est évidemment pas un
hasard dans la bouche d'alain carignon
qui dit contrepartie dit corruption qui
dit avantages du recel d'abus de biens
sociaux
un délit nettement moins grave au regard
du code pénal
quatre jours après la double tuerie de
solliès-pont et de cuers les gendarmes
et tout un village tente toujours de
comprendre les motivations du jeune eric
saison qui a tué 13 personnes de
sang-froid reporta fille boisserie
stéphane chopin brutalement par un
samedi de septembre
ce visage d'adolescent est devenu celui
de la folie une folie meurtrière qui a
d'abord frappé une famille entre les
murs trop étouffant d'une maison avant
de s'abattre au hasard d'une errance sur
neuf habitants d'un village voisin
depuis le curé de cuers recueil cette
parole qui a un besoin absolu de
s'écouler un grand désarroi
on découvre soudain que tout peut
s'arrêter on avait plein de projets on a
on veut faire des choses partira
dimanche et passer une bonne journée
dimanche tout d'un coup tout s'arrête
très tôt le matin
une minute de silence a ouvert le
conseil municipal de ce mercredi avant
que le colonel de gendarmerie présente
ses dernières conclusions
la mésentente familiale la solitude la
fascination pour la violence
tout cela les habitants de qr sont déjà
tournés mille fois dans leur tête en
sachant qu'au fond
l'inconcevable l'emportent celui d'une
violence froide déterminée qui a plongé
tout le monde dans le deuil
on ira pas ces jurys restera gravé ça
pour être ravis sera gravé et tous les
amis qu'on a perdus vont leur vient de
voir une maman qui est père de cinq
enfants
ses mains
ça me fait de la peine en dessous ce
qu'aime j'ai pas du moins si vous tuez
quelqu'un la baronne produire tous ce
soir cuers n'attend qu'une seule chose
pouvoir enterrer ses morts non pas pour
oublier
mais pour trouver un peu de repos en
france cette tuerie est la plus
meurtrière depuis juillet 89 depuis le
jour où à lux yole dans le doubs un
homme de 31 ans christian dormiez avait
tué 14 personnes dont sa mère et sa
soeur
les experts l'avaient ensuite déclaré
irresponsable sur le plan pénal
six ans après le traumatisme
psychologique at il été surmontées par
les proches des victimes
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux pascal
tous ces bouts guillaume faudra vu d'ici
la tuerie de tuers a un goût plus amer
qu'ailleurs luxe yole porte encore le
deuil de son carnage et ses 150
habitants ont décidé pour la plupart de
ne plus jamais en parler publiquement
c'était le 12 juillet 89 veille de bâle
christian dornier 31 ans tué 14
personnes avec la même détermination que
le jeune meurtrier de cuers
il est aujourd'hui interné dans un
service psychiatrique spécialisé
après avoir été jugé irresponsable par
les experts jeanine tu n' a pas suivis
très longtemps les séances collectives
organisées par un psycho sociologue
après le drame
elle a échappé de très peu au meurtrier
qui l'a blessé au bras
sa thérapie à elle c'est de raconter et
malgré la volonté d'un retour à la
normale le village n'est plus comme
avant
la peur est encore là si vous allez
devoir faire
oui moi je sais je vous assure qu'à
partir des valeurs tirent et elle a
perdu son mari dans le drame elle n'a
qu'un conseil à donner aux victimes
varoise lutter contre l' isolement
qu'elles ressentent aujourd'hui
bon au départ on s'est beaucoup occupé
nous on ne peut pas ne pas dire le
contraire mais maintenant on n'intéresse
plus personne
tous en tout cas en premier une chose
leur porte est ouverte aux proches des
victimes de cuers le mot solidarité a
ici un sens tout particulier
ouverture à metz du procès de francis
heaulme accusé du meurtre et du viol
d'une fillette de 14 ans et demi en mai
81 11
francis heaulme a déjà été condamné l'an
dernier à 20 ans de réclusion criminelle
pour un autre meurtre et il est mis en
examen pour huit autres crimes de sang
la cour d'assises s'est penché
aujourd'hui sur la personnalité de ce
tueur en série compte rendu d'audience
valérie remis joseph vous explique
francis heaulme n'a ni remords ni
sentiment de culpabilité
il n'est pas dément mais il est
indubitablement psychopathique ce sont
les mots d innombrables psychiatre que
francis heaulme a rencontrés tout au
long de son périple judiciaire
un périple il a d'abord commencé sur les
routes france en huit ans heaulme est
soupçonné d'avoir participé à une
dizaine de meneurs
issu d'une famille violente et
alcoolique on le met d'abord un
adolescent perturbé puis un adulte très
impulsif
ces carences affectives son faible
coefficient intellectuel et son
intolérance à la frustration ont fini
par faire de lui peut-être l'un des plus
grands tueurs en série
on peut la part des traitement sélectif
mais ces traitements sédatifs ne traîne
pas le problème de fond et je crois que
ce serait toute une prise en charge
peut-être de son histoire de tout ce
qu'il a vécu antérieurement
mais ce qu'il avait plu enterrement
enfin ils n'ont pas mais il n'a aucune
demande de prise en charge francis
heaulme est-il curable à cette question
là les psychiatres hésite puis à vous
sans doute pour enfin se dire désarmé
quant au traitement face à une telle
personnalité
francis heaulme après avoir été à un cap
pour les gendarmes à un cap pour la
justice est aussi un peu un cas pour les
experts le ministre des finances a lancé
un beau pavé dans la mare fiscal à
l'occasion d'une interview à nos
confrères de l'express jean arthuis se
prononce en effet en faveur d'une
extension de l'impôt sur le revenu au
français qui ne le paie pas actuellement
et à l'extension de la csg à l'ensemble
des revenus
dans l'esprit du gouvernement cette
réforme entraînerait un transfert de 4 à
500 milliards de francs qui permettrait
de baisser significativement les
cotisations sociales
françoise laborde premières réformes
envisagées la csg elle est prélevée
directement à la source
essentiellement sur les revenus du
travail élargir la csg cela suppose de
tacler ceux qui ont sont exonérés
rmistes chômeurs en dessous du niveau du
smic
retraités non imposables allocataires de
prestations familiales mais élargir la
csg cela veut dire aussi pacsé l'epargne
par exemple les livres et à l'écho des
villes épargne logement l'assurance vie
ou les sica contrepartie de ces
alourdissement envisager les cotisations
sociales payées par les salariés
seraient elles diminué deuxième réforme
l'impôt sur le revenu aujourd'hui 15
millions de foyers ils sont soumis 13
millions en sont exonérés objectifs de
la réforme supprimer un certain nombre
d'abattements de déduction est aussi
ramener la tranche supérieure
d'imposition de 56,8 à 40 % début d'une
polémique n'est ce pas là un cadeau aux
plus riches
aujourd'hui la tranche supérieure est
payé par par peu de contribuables parce
que il ya un certain nombre
d'abattements de réduction qui font que
l'on contourne la tranche supérieure je
voudrais aussi que chacun soit bien
conscient que nous vivons à l'heure de
la mondialisation et que par excès
d'impôts
certains contribuables ce que vous
appelez les riches peuvent être tentés
de déplacer leur assiette de cotisations
étant revenu dans d'autres pays
sous d'autres cieux plus accueillants
le ministre la firme l'objectif est de
diminuer globalement le poids des
prélèvements obligatoires
en tout état de cause l'élargissement de
la csg et la refonte de l'impôt sur le
revenu pourrait débuter en 96
mais ce grand chantier durera au moins
quatre ready actuellement journées
parlementaires ans marles les dirigeants
socialistes ont très vivement réagi aux
projets fiscaux du gouvernement henri
emmanuelli accuse par exemple le
ministre de l'économie de vouloir le
site étendre le nombre des cotisants à
la csg pour que les riches mais moins
sur place roland sicard jean-françois
chevet quand les socialistes entrent
dans la danse
en général c'est qu'ils sont en forme
et lorsque michel rocard lui même se
lance dans un flamenco endiablé
c'est que le ps se sent vraiment le vent
en poupe c'est que chaque jour les
socialistes ont l'impression de pouvoir
marquer des points aujourd'hui c'est la
réforme de la fiscalité envisagée par le
ministre des finances qui les
intéressent attaques frontales des
responsables du ps en commençant par le
créateur de la csc va devenir
intolérable et ça c'est pas un service
rendu aux grilles carbone d'un produit
interdit l'érable il est frotté on peut
plus le faire sérieusement c'est
extrêmement rare et si la lhjmq et
entreprend de gouvernement c'est à mon
avis les inspecteurs et moi je reconnais
plus mon enfant on attendait des mesures
fortes contre le chômage et on a en fait
un matraquage fiscal qui va aggraver la
fracture sociale faire payer un peu tous
ne sont pas aujourd'hui pour que les
riches paix - c'est sûrement pas dans ce
sens là que les socialistes agit en
conclusion les socialistes veulent jouer
à fond leur rôle d'opposant réforme de
la fiscalité mais aussi budget 96 qu'ils
refuseront de voter et la semaine
prochaine le ps montera au créneau à
l'assemblée nationale
la phase d'observation est ternie alain
juppé de la confirmer tout à l'heure
lors d'une réunion à huis clos avec des
dirigeants du rpr il sera bien candidat
à la présidence du mouvement gaulliste
lors des prochaines assises de ce
mouvement le 15 octobre
alerte rouge pour la sécurité sociale
aux toutes dernières nouvelles le besoin
de trésorerie autrement dit le découvert
vient de dépasser les 90 milliards de
francs et devrait atteindre les 110
milliards à la fin de cette année la
cour des comptes qui vient de se pencher
sur ceux de la sécu et pai ne l'est pas
et les responsables des caisses pour
l'opacité de leur gestion
reportage le rang bas prendre première
la cour des comptes scrutent à la loupe
les comptes de la sécu et le fait savoir
l'état est mis en cause pour avoir
laissé filer le déficit depuis des
années le trou est de 120 milliards pour
94 et 95 surtout la cour des comptes
reproche l'opacité qui règne sur des
sommes énormes la sécurité sociale
c'est énormément d'argent plus d'argent
que nettement 2500 milliards est
tellement d'argent on a du mal à y
penser
eh bien les comptes de la sécurité
sociale ne sont pas du tout si clair que
les comptes de l'état sur le terrain ce
manque de clarté autorise des gestions
très différentes
il y a les bons élèves qui parviennent à
maîtriser l'évolution des dépenses comme
ici à créteil +2 et demi pour cent
seulement cette année plusieurs façons
d'agir et plusieurs en rien tout d'abord
la prévention en amont c'est la gestion
du risque bien comprise ensuite sur le
terrain la responsabilisation
responsabilisation des médecins
responsabilisation des assurés sociaux
responsabilisation de tous les
professionnels de la santé
et puis il ya des caisses comme ici à
beauvais où les remboursements des
assurés 100 vols + 10 % cette année une
dérive financière certes mais aussi un
choix du directeur
nous essayons surtout des gestionnaires
mais nous gérons une institution sociale
ça c'est clair
faut-il arrêter la prise en charge de
certaines prestations faut-il comme je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure ne plus
accorder la carte santé aux rmistes ou
aux personnes défavorisées
c'est aussi à ce genre de questions et à
la lumière du rapport de la cour des
comptes que le parlement et le
gouvernement devront répondre ces
prochains mois en conclusion la cour des
comptes note que face à l'ampleur des
déficits du régime général 120 milliards
de francs à la fin de cette année des
mesures de redressement s'impose dans
les plus brefs délais grève des hôtesses
et des stewards 75% des vols ont été
assurés aujourd'hui sur air france et
environ 60% sur air inter un mouvement
qui continue demain et qui pourrait
annoncer d'autres conflits chez des
salariés inquiets de leur avenir
professionnel et qui s'agacent de plus
en plus de la réputation de privilégie
qui l'aurait fait
reportage pascal golomer filles ont
choisi en français ou en anglais le
résultat elle même beaucoup d'avions
n'ont pas décollé aujourd'hui 45 vols
annulés chez air france 170 sièges inter
et ça continue demain attentes et
collèges
on comprend pas on sait qu'ils sont
vraiment dans la merde il ya le monstre
pourquoi active et encore ces grèves
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent détruire une
vie de travail dans trois ans il y aura
plus de monopole qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire ça je prendrais yahoo autre chose
chetout faut que l'opinion publique le
sachent que la grève c'est le dernier
recours que moi même je suis absolument
pas heureux de faire la grève ça ne me
fait pas plaisir dans la mesure où tout
personnel gréviste perd de l'argent
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui à l'heure
actuelle personne n'a envie de perdre de
l'argent et on n'a pas du tout envie non
plus que notre entreprise continue à
perdre de l'argent mais là c'est une
question de survie
on avait signé un accord il ya un an
pour un gain de productivité on a attend
aujourd'hui ce gain de productivité
aujourd'hui on nous demande de faire
encore plus toujours plus alors le
problème c'est de savoir quand ça va
s'arrêter
en fait c'est la réforme du métier de
stewards que refusent les grévistes
une réforme lancée par la direction
d'air france à partir d'un constat le
personnel navigant coûterait trop cher
par rapport à la concurrence européenne
alors on veut recruter à moindre salaire
et faire redescendre au sol les stewards
de 15 ans de service entre autres
mesures il faut avoir la concurrence
qu'on nous fait sur les amériques
american airlines et british airways
lufthansa aujourd'hui cassent les prix
et on n'a pas le choix nous aussi en
dois-je c'était notre situation bloquée
à air france et le personnel navigant
d'air inter suit le mouvement par
inquiétude pour l'avenir même s'il a
aucune réforme n'est annoncée pour
l'instant polémique après l'annoncé hier
par alain juppé d'une mission confiée à
trois députés ni sont destinées à
traquer les abus en matière de chômeurs
d'immigration et surtout de rmi la
socialiste martine aubry se déclare
contre et et reproche au premier
ministre je cite de montrer du doigt les
plus fragiles comme étant responsable
des difficultés financières du pays
en ce jour de saint vincent de paul le
secours populaire publié un rapport d'où
il ressort qu'une large part des exclus
ne bénéficie pas du rmi et que de plus
en plus les associations caritatives
sont amenés à pallier les carences de
l'état
reportage valérie fournis ou 1000
dollars dont deux envois
enfin écouter gioanni bertal haut depuis
huit mois qu'ils expliquent son cas aux
services sociaux
seul le secours catholique l'a pris en
charge le loge le nourrit et travaille
maintenant à sa réinsertion
d'ailleurs étonnamment c'est une
assistante sociale qui l'a envoyé ici
services sociaux c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu démerdez vous excusez
moi le terme on veut bien noté on va
bien côté mais on peut rien faire
adressez vous à c'était très étonné dans
la mesure où on a cotisé quand même pas
mal d'années pour avoir justement
bénéficier de certaines aides peuvent se
trouver d'un seul coup à en avoir besoin
et se trouvait presque portes se fermer
ça paraît un peu un peu bizarre comme
lui 56 % des personnes qui se présentent
au secours catholique
le fond sur les conseils des services
sociaux publics vous avez des secteurs
vacants d'assistante sociale dans un
département si vous serez comme la nôtre
c'est absolument pas normal
alors non seulement vous avez des
secteurs à caen mais vous avez des des
remplacements qui ne ce qui ne se
remplace pas un dd des congés de maladie
etc
aujourd'hui où les associations sont
affrontés à des demandes en direct au
lieu je n'irai de passer par les
circuits officiels
résultat le secours catholique est
débordé comme toutes les autres
associations caritatives
face à ce désengagement de l'état l'état
ne prend pas suffisamment ses
responsabilités trop souvent ils
considèrent que nous sommes des
auxiliaires des pouvoirs publics alors
que nous nous considérons notre activité
pour aiguillonner les pouvoirs publics à
court de financement et surtout de dons
privés
les associations caritatives n'arrive
plus à suivre d'autant plus que l'état
les taxes comme des entreprises
après les très pauvres les très riches
la famille agnelli qui contrôle
notamment fiat va devenir le premier
actionnaire du club méditerranée une
famille italienne qui s'intéressent
décidément beaucoup au capital français
comme nous l'expliquent alain bosc entre
gens de bonne famille on se marie on
fait alliance
la famille agnelli c'est un empire qui
contrôle fiat en italie plus des
sociétés en asie en extrême-orient et en
france grâce à des participations dans
les groupes bolloré saint louis dans
l'immobilier parisien
et dans les vignobles de château margaux
la famille trigano est numéro un mondial
des villages de vacances
elle est présente dans 38 pays grâce à
ces clubs dans les deux clans on se fait
une certaine idée de la gestion
elle doit être à la fois familial et
internationale le jour où trigano
annonce une augmentation du capital de
900 millions de francs
la plupart des actionnaires mettent la
main à la poche mais c'est à la famille
agnelli déjà actionnaires que le pdg du
club med va proposer la plus grosse
participation agnelli devient le premier
actionnaire du club avec 13 % du capital
pour serge trigano l'arrivée du célèbre
industriel italien est une marque
supplémentaire de prestige objectif
racheter 100% de la filiale américaine
du club construit revenue au village et
rénover les sites les plus anciens
le groupement israélien a approuvé
aujourd'hui la corde d'extension de
l'autonomie en cisjordanie qui doit être
officiellement paraphé demain à
washington sur la route des états-unis
yasser arafat a fait escale à paris
l'occasion de rencontrer jacques chirac
l elysée mais aussi d'embrasser sa fille
reporte à philippe rochot rouge agneau
ce bébé dans les bras de madame arafat
zahwa la fille du chef de noël paix et
de soi arafat né à paris il y a deux
mois et l'assistera à la signature des
accords de washington est peut-être
connaîtra-t-elle plus tard l'état
palestinien qui se dessine c'est pour
présenter à jacques chirac le texte des
accords sur l'extension de l'autonomie
palestinienne qu arafat a fait escale à
paris la france donne chaque année 250
millions de francs à l'autorité
palestinienne
elle est donc partie prenante à l'accord
dont la signature sera suivie de la
libération de plus de 5000 prisonniers
palestiniens a été un élément très
important de la colle c'est que la
libération des prisonniers se fait juste
après la signature de l'accord le chef
de l'ol paie par ainsi à washington avec
le soutien total de la france
c'est une paix des braves entre nous et
les israéliens
c'est pour ça que j'utilise le même perm
que le général de gaulle à utiliser pour
l'algérie cette peine
c'est d'essayer beaucoup de courage de
parts de zawa attendu pendant une heure
que son père ait fini ses entretiens
avec le président jacques chirac avant
de quitter paris pour la première fois
avec son père
sa mère ensemble mais après la fête de
washington va commencer l'épreuve de
vérité l'armée israélienne a dix jours
pour se retirer des principales villes
de cisjordanie et permettre ainsi aux
palestiniens d'élire leurs représentants
et de gagner un peu de souveraineté sur
la cisjordanie occupée à propos de la
signature de cet accord de paix gérard
leclerc recevra demain 7h 50 dans les 4
vérités
le secrétaire général du parti
travailliste israélien la guerre en
bosnie pour la première fois le
gouvernement français par la bouche de
charles millon a confirmé officiellement
que les deux pilotes français a battu le
30 août dernier au dessus de la bosnie
avait été prise en charge par les forces
militaire bosno serbes cet équipage est
composé de deux officiers de la base de
nancy c'est lorsque nous avons eu
connaissance par les serbes de belgrade
que les pilotes étaient vivants qu'ils
étaient prisonniers parce que nous avons
eu aussi connaissance qu'il y avait des
agences de presse qui auraient des
photos que nous avons jugé utile de
faire connaître l'identité
bien sûr après avoir prévenu les
familles comme il se doit
sur le plan politique sous l'impulsion
des américains serbes croates et
bosniaques ont fait hier soir à new york
un nouveau petit pas vers la paix en
définissant les grandes lignes des
futures structures de l'état de bosnie
herzégovine mais la mise en oeuvre de
cet accord s'annonce particulièrement
délicate
la question notamment du partage
territorial reste entière l'un des
voiliers de greenpeace le vega a été
arraisonné dans la zone des 12 milles
autour de mûrois un seul bateau de
greenpeace reste actuellement dans cette
zone
tous les autres ayant été arraisonné ou
saisi cette campagne anti nucléaires en
polynésie française a semble-t-il
provoqué quelques remous au sein même de
cette organisation avec entre autres le
renvoi de quelques responsables
reportage vers liga l'yonne vincent à
bord c'était avant même le premier tir
nucléaire le 1er septembre et déjà
greenpeace
commencez à perdre ses pièces maîtresses
dans la bataille navale du pacifique
deux navires un hélicoptère mais aussi
des canaux des parachutes et surplus du
matériel de transmission par satellite
confisqué et cela devait continuer après
le rainbow warrior ii le greenpeace et
d'hélicoptères hier c'était au tour du v
gard d'être arraisonné le laissant à
greenpeace qu'un seul navire dans la
zone de murs revoir ses revers plus ou
moins attendu coûterait 80 millions de
francs à l'organisation écologiste soit
plus de 10% de son budget annuel alors
que ce budget est en baisse continue
depuis cinq ans la nouvelle direction de
greenpeace veut donc resserrer les
boulons et changer de cap
vous ne pouvez pas demander à une
organisation d'être identique à ce
qu'elle était ya 25 ans une organisation
sa bouche de l'intérieur parce que ça
évolue
ça bouge aussi parce que l'extérieur
évolué parce que les dangers écologiques
à l'extérieur évolué et c'est normal
qu'une organisation évolué c'est normal
que de temps en temps il ya des
changements de stratégie
alors changement de stratégie ulrich
organe directeur de la campagne
antinucléaire est contraint de
démissionner après avoir mis en cause
les procédés de sa coordinatrice
stéphanie mills elle même ne verra pas
son contrat renouvelé
greenpeace glisse peu à peu d'une
philosophie pure et dure celle de
l'action refusant tout compromis à une
stratégie aujourd'hui plus belle plus
prête au dialogue
incarnée par son nouveau directeur t-il
au bold à l'avenir disent les membres de
l'organisation
il faudra comprendre l'adversaire et
proposer des solutions
quand le sex symbol des années 60
rencontres le pape ces pourparlers
animaux brigitte bardot a fêté
aujourd'hui au vatican la saint françois
d'assise le protecteur des animaux avec
une semaine d'avancé sur le calendrier
abb participé ce matin à cette audience
papale avec une quarantaine de
représentants d'associations chargée de
la protection des espèces animales
jean paul ii lui a confié qu'il
n'oubliait jamais les animaux et qu'il
portait toujours dans son coeur
l'exemple de saint françois d'assise
j'ai pardo s'est déclaré très ému au
point d'en oublier son italien lors de
son nez
change avec le pain sans transition
comme dirait l'autre un petit tour au
mondial des deux roues qui ouvre ses
portes vendredi à paris la part la plus
importante du marché des deux roues en
france reste le scooter avec 250 mille
engins vendu l'an dernier en compagnie
de marc maisonneuve et de jean louis
hamelin un petit tour en prenant bien
garde aux portes hier à 14 ans pour
apprendre l'autonomie et à 18 ans pour
être franchement indépendant alors vous
vraiment envie d'aller voir des copains
dont tr min le bus les parents après les
petits nouveaux effectivement présenté
au salon
anne-sophie 17 ans dans le rôle de
l'essayeur le gros du marché avec 200
milles scooter non immatriculés vendus
en 94 dans six mois elle passera son
permis voiture
ce n'est que dans une vingtaine d'années
qu'elle reviendra peut-être housse
coûtera des vies car c'est l'autre
partie des consommateurs
la solution à l'engorgement urbain au
problème du stationnement l'hôtel cadres
dynamiques faible thalia les 35 ans ex
copain des professions libérales qui ont
besoin de leur scooter pour pour aller
partout et être à leur est propre sur
soi
mais soit l'inversé rendez vous mais pas
de problème pas
c'est beaucoup de cher en entretien vous
voyez rien antivol tous les ans de ça
c'est vraiment de la merde vous faut
changer tous les ans 500 francs je suis
de l'huile de l'essence et finkie
prévisions quant à août c'est tout
comment vous êtes toujours alors avec ça
va écouter
je vais essayer de l'être si vous me
lâcher je vais essayer d'être à l'heure
le vol le problème majeur du scooter les
constructeurs ont trouvé une solution
l'antivol intégrer les voleurs sont en
panne pour l'instant
à bogota aux championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste l'australien sean
kelly a remporté l'épreuve du kilomètre
devant le favori et français florian
rousseau médaille d'argent donc et qui
peut toujours se consoler en sachant que
son vainqueur a battu le record du monde
de la spécialité déception compenser
dans le camp français par la victoire de
fer et manier dans le keirin qui a donc
parcouru les 200 mètres de cette
distance en 10 secondes et 598 millièmes
le sprinteur a dédié sa victoire à son
compatriote patrice upeace accidenté à
l'entraînement vendredi et qui risque de
rester hémiplégique football en match
retour du premier tour de la coupe uefa
auxerre et lyon se sont qualifiés
logiquement hier et monaco a été
normalement éliminer les vraies
surprises de la soirée sont venues de la
chute de deux grands clubs européens
l'inter de milan et manchester united
manchester aura tout tenté face à
volgograd même schmeichel le goal
anglais marquent un but égalisateur de
la tête à la 89e minute mais cela ne
suffit pas les coéquipiers de cantona
avait la poisse hier soir à la mi-temps
il était mené 2-0 grâce appelé burrus le
premier signé ici n leader goss
le deuxième est l'oeuvre de dire et et
nicole manchester va ensuite dominé
toute la deuxième période avec les
occasions incroyables
c'est finalement ce colas qui inscrira
le premier but des reds la suite de
l'histoire on la connaît de partout
score final et quant aux ne jouera donc
pas ces familles la coupe d'europe
un autre grand d'europe est tombé hier
soir l'inter de milan en bleu et toutes
ses stars
battu par la petite équipe suisse de
lugano 1 0 sur ce coup franc et se
louper du cardia millénaire pailloux cas
l'arrivée cette année du nouvel
entraîneur suarez n'aura donc pas donner
le coup de fouet à escompter à cette
équipe milanaise qui est actuellement
classé dans les profondeurs du
championnat italien
à luxembourg les lensois se sont
qualifiés tout à l'heure sans grand
problème c'est à 0 face à l'avenir
beggen cinéma a sorti aujourd'hui sur
nos grands écrans de la fleur de mon
secret le onzième film de pedro
almodovar le réalisateur espagnol entre
autres de femmes au bord de la crise de
nerfs ou encore talons aiguilles cette
fois le spécialiste des comédies
sulfureuse a tourné un drame
reportage pascal dessauges véronique
barrau tant que tu voulais c'est qu'elle
fait un drame donc la vie de l'héroïne
les auteurs à succès de romans à l'eau
de rose mais dont la vie privée est loin
dans les trains ir qui décide un beau
jour de ne plus écrire que des histoires
tristes
au grand dam de ces éditeurs qui va
s'identifier à une héroïne qui se plaît
à l'étanchéité des malades d'un hôpital
et qui par dessus le marché une belle
mère junkie un fils [ __ ] et qui en plus
n'est que les [ __ ]
peut-être mais c'est la réalité aliciens
la réalité mais la réalité moi j'en ai
plus qu'il n'en faut à la maison car
agitée c'est bon pour les journaux et la
télévision ne regarde le résultat de
montrer la réalité je payais ton portes
de l'exposition la réalité devrait
totalement interdite
je parle de tous ceux qui fuient la
réalité exemple le cinéma américain il
fuit la réalité c'est le cinéma qui
parle le moins de la réalité malgré les
apparences dans le monde du
divertissement on a peur de tout les
gens qui dans leurs films et pièces de
théâtre
je parle de la réalité sans doute parce
que la vérité ne nous plaît pas mais
comme pedro almodovar est un
incorrigible optimiste tout ça ne finira
pas trop mal
tour à tour ils ont dit gough
l'affleurement ce fait est donc un
tendre hommage à une poignée de femmes
toujours au bord de la piste
le tien compris que pour changer la
réalité il fallait commencer par
accepter de l'ampleur blanc sas avant de
souhaiter une excellente soirée l écoute
de nos programmes ces images
impressionnantes dumont voix pays ou
dans le nord de la nouvelle zélande qui
a été à nouveau secoué la nuit dernière
par de violentes éruptions volcaniques
qui ont propulsé les ponots d'evry à des
milliers de mètres d'altitude
des sangles été retrouvés jusqu'à 70 km
du site
l'orignal est un volcan les cendres 53
des torrents d'eau et de boue avec
emporté un pont de chemin de fer et le
train et le franchisé entraînant dans la
mort 150 voyageurs des relais journal en
compagnie de philippe lefait vers minuit
dans un instant la météo signé sophie
davant bonne fête aux 20 cents à 13
heures vous retrouver patrick chêne et
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver à
20h excellente soirée merci